We're almost at the end of the year.
We're almost at the end of the show.
That's right. We've had some amazing guests
this year Kelly Clarkson, Simone Biles, Jay
Pharoah as Kevin Hart.
Yeah, yeah. Um, but you know who I missed
from last year?
Uh, Jon Hamm, Kevin Bacon, Halle Berry.
You just you saying famous people with food
names.
Condoleezza Rice.
That was a good that's a good one.
But no, even better.
Remember this I still love corn.
Yeah, I get to meet the actual Kenan and Kel
like, I'm so funny.
Might make me cracking up.
You heard a Kevin Hart before?
You probably know this, Kel, but I never even
knew Kevin Hart until you told me
this. This is. This is.
This is Kevin Hart here.
He keep calling me Kel. I know.
Kel. Get one that funny, Kel.
He was adorable.
He was adorable. I love how he say the word
corn. He. He say corn.
Yeah, yeah. You like that?
I'm here with you. I didn't think the kid was
adorable, okay? I didn't yeah, I didn't I
didn't think he was adorable at all.
I really feel like that kid needs to be
humbled. Okay. Yes.
All right. Yes. Well, he's a year older now,
so maybe he's changed. Let's find out.
Here he is, the corn kid.
Hi, Keenan. Hi, Kel.
Oh, God.
Hey. What in the.
Whoa. He changed a little bit.
Yeah, a little.
He must have put some testosterone in his
comb. Yeah. Very good.
I want to say, Mr. Corn kid, you you look all
grown up. You got facial hair and
everything, huh? Yeah, I just started
puberty. Okay, good.
Congratulations. What else you been up to?
You're still into the corn?
Corns..
Okay, I guess, but you know what?
I'm really into, Porn.
Oh, what did you say?
I'm sorry. Say what now? What'd you say,
Corn kid? Porn?
Is he talking about porn? Did you say he's
talking about porn? Right? I believe
he is. Oh, you
bet your ass I'm talking about porn.
Oh, okay.
It porn is a beautiful thing.
It's way better than corn.
Oh, there's all types of porn.
Stepmom porn, interracial porn, Japanese
cartoon porn.
Green porn.
Oh, I could go on and on.
Let's get him out of here before he gets his
cancelled.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Get him out of here.
Thank you. I don't have any pants on.
All right, your perverted ass up off the
screen.
Get your perverted. Happy New year.
Happy new year, corn.